well hey everybody happy Monday it's the
week before Christmas yeah which is
crazy yeah I can't [__] believe that
that Christmas is next Monday man I got
presents I got a wrap I know yours are
supposed to be coming tomorrow or at
least one of them is and then the other
one's coming later in the week so I got
to I got to wrap that at some point all
kinds of [__] [__] went up for sale
[__] that I bought for myself too but
[__] I was like wait a minute no I'm not
letting that [__] 300 [__]
blackout Barrel go for [__] 40 bucks
no way I'm having that Christmas present
to myself yeah yeah yeah that [__] was
100 150 bucks last month it's 40 now now
I'm going to get that that's okay you
can buy yourself stuff for Christmas I
don't mind I'm building a 300 Blackout
up the thing about it is like whenever
you ask me like what I want for
Christmas I can't think of a single
[__] thing like I'm sure there's a
lot of things I want but what I'm ask
I'm just kind of like uh I don't know
you know what I mean I can't think of
anything now this right
here here's the movie right here my boy
Zan sent this zanada is here in the chat
sent us this me and Zan talk all the
time [__] uh on uh uh D we DM all the
time [__] for been for years man how
long we known each other now man [__]
probably like six years I feel like it's
been a while yeah yeah but he's a good
cat man and um [__] uh we did a lot
of [__] online together but he sent me
this thing right here it's called yeah
we got it yesterday Cocaine Cowboys and
I thought it was going to be uh DVD but
this is actually the Blu-ray Edition
yeah it's fancy which is good and it's a
updated version of this they remastered
this when and when you know well yeah
the original one came out in 2006 and it
was just called Cocaine Cowboys yeah and
then this one has like a whole bunch of
extra footage yeah and um they kind of
like took I guess they took some of the
old [__] out that wasn't relevant
anymore whatever so this one is actually
called Cocaine Cowboys reloaded and this
came out in 2014 so this is like an
update yeah and one the most awesome
thing about this it's a lot of awesome
[__] about this but one of the things
that they [__] changed is it has a
new retro wave soundtrack yeah [__]
well it's and yon Hammer yeah does the
music for this Tom was very impressed
because as soon as yon hammer's name
came up in the in the um credits I was
like oh the guy that did the music for
Miami Vice and Tom's like how do you
know this [__] yeah how you [__] know
this [__] I'm just like I don't know
rumors I just like everything that
happened in the'80s is just kind of like
indelibly like in my brain and I can't
get rid of it we are children of the 8S
so yeah when I was in high school man
there was a [__] series called Miami
Vice and they talked about Florida and
Miami as if it was another country and
now that I've moved here it was it's
kind of its own thing it's a very weird
place it is it was I've only been there
a couple of times but it's a very weird
place Florida was like an and it even
says so in in this in this documentary
and this documentary is more like an
action movie it shows the [__] dead
bodies and everything okay yeah we'll
get into that it's good yeah it's really
really good okay so it's don't don't
don't think this is going to be a dry
stale watch this is [__] awesome all
right great soundtrack uh great
storytelling from Cartel assassins and
[__] [__] you know there just every
detail quite cool yeah and it's long
it's like two and half hours so it's
like really like which is longer than
the original I think this is the new
edit I think I think Zan said the
original was about only two hours long
this yeah so like I said they added a
lot more context and a lot more um
interviews and stuff and they updated
stuff that had happened subsequently
before cocaine Florida was kind of like
Alabama all right just a bunch of old
people down in Miami you know uh in in
in apartments highrise
Apartments uh there was money there but
it not not a whole lot it was kind of a
small town in much the same way that
Orlando was just kind of like a tiny
Podunk swamp town before Disney came um
and then it exploded like in tourism
right but um Miami was kind of the same
it was just kind of like I don't know if
I'd go so far as say it was a small town
but it was pretty Podunk and uh Florida
really forever for hundreds of years
Florida is older than the United States
it's always been kind of a a half breed
state in a weird weird way it's a weird
place it's it's like a southern
anglosaxon But Central America at the
same time quite cool it's been pirates
here and this is just an extension of
Florida's pirate age these are modern
pirates pretty much yeah yeah and they
were Florida rednecks with Cocaine
Cowboys from from [__] Colombia yeah
shooting the [__] place up like they
they thought they were back in Colombia
it's great it's a great F I mean one
minute they were [__] riding horses
in Columbia shooting at each other then
the next minute they're in downtown
[__] Miami driving in the freeways at
100 miles hour in Ferrari shooting each
other with m t shooting at each other
from and then that you know you had all
kinds of [__] you had like female cartel
leaders trying to hit female senators
because she didn't like what she said on
television she's like I'm going to kill
that [__] yeah I'm GNA kill that [__]
and the Assassin's going no no this no
you can't do that you can't kill a here
like we're going to get in big trouble
it's like bad for business but she was
just man that's a grisela Blanco that
we're talking about who they called the
Godmother godmother she's going to get
into the details I'm just laying it out
first so I'm hyping the subject so she
can get into it and and it [__] shows
a lot of good [__] in this uh in this
documentary and uh it introduces you to
the surviving players and why they you
know not many of them left not many of
them left but most of them got gunned
down yeah but or in prison yeah or in
prison well most interesting one was a a
cartel assassin okay he killed a bunch
of people Ry I think his name that was
his rivy R II yeah another one was a uh
born and raised Florida redneck who was
a pilot who was one of their main
Smugglers that was Mickey Monday right
Mickey Monday somebody said uh he were
just talking about all the nightclubs
that they built and all the money they
had and him just dropping $30,000 a
night and [__] nightclubs get handing
out free bottles of D Perry on and and
just just the lives that they live it's
[__] bizarre and just how crooked the
banks were and how the skyline of Miami
just exploded overnight and all those
[__] high-rise buildings built on
cocaine money and I mean that's not
really an exaggeration exaggeration when
people say that that myy was like and
actually the original um the guy that uh
wrote and directed all of these uh
Cocaine Cowboys series because there's a
whole bunch of them um he actually
wanted to call this the City built on
snow was what the original title was and
like I said and they say this several
times in the documentary too like people
that live there and like you know were
covering it like for the media or
whatever and they're just like you know
when people say that Miami was a City
built on cocaine they're not
exaggerating that is absolutely the case
and here's the thing you know you may
have some people in Europe or other
countries go where were the police oh
you know no way this could have never
happened the would have stopped the cops
were helping some of the cops were
helping cops were helping important a
lot of the cops were helping yeah a lot
of the a lot of the judges and the cops
that weren't helping were freaking out
because they were completely outgunned
yeah uh by the criminals and like there
wasn't really anything they could do
they they said in they had so many
murders that they just didn't have
enough cops and they said a bunch of
cops quit because they're like [__] this
[__] you know what I mean because the
murder rate was so high and and all
these guys that started this came from
was a mixture of Cuba and Colombia but
they talk about it in this in this
documentary Castro basically flushed his
toilet into the United States that's the
terminology yes he said that literally
[__] like people that came that were
refugees were fine but he he also like
released a bunch of people from prisons
yeah yeah he he released thousands of
thousands of people from from uh from
Cuban prisons and as soon as they got
here fing rapes jumped up 70 something
per [__] murders just skyrocketed
these guys if they just liked your car
they just killed you and took your car
if they thought you were a good-looking
girl they just [__] took it okay and
man they got American politicians state
level politicians saying [__] back then
that they never would say today is like
Civilization Society was built for
civilized human beings because these
people barely register as human beings
these aren't human beings these people
are subhuman and he's talking about
those convicts that they let out of damn
Cuban prison they were [__] killing
everybody and then uh most of the [__]
that was happening with in the Cartel
Wars here they were Colombians that had
lived there for a long time but they
were all illegal aliens uh they got here
because they owned their own airplanes
and their own ships yeah they didn't and
there was if you owned your own airplane
you could just walk right in you could
just fly in and just land it
local private airport there's no
passports or anything you got tons and
tons of cocaine that's what they did I
mean they weren real stringent back they
weren't they still aren't a private
private if you have a private airplane
and certain certain airports you you
just for it would be much harder now
harder much harder nowadays but you
could just land the airplane but like
back in the 70s and 80s and I think this
is true of anything cuz holy [__] man
back in the if you watch movies like
from the 70s and ' 80s you could just
you were going on a flight you could
just into a [__] airport like 5
minutes before the plane was going to
take off oh yeah okay get on the plane
it's like they don't know who the [__]
you are they look at your ID or nothing
and it's just kind people like flew
places under fake names and [__] like
that you would never get away with the
Assassins the Assassins loaded up a
bunch of [__] full auto ma 10s with
suppressors and [__] and put them in the
suitcases and just put them in the
airplane they were like they got busted
but a couple times but I'm sure like
that one time they got busted I'm sure
they did it a bunch of times yeah they
didn't really care what was in you but
the thing is is that we used to
transport weapons in the luggage all the
time you know for hunting rifles and
[__] you can but there's just like
rules about whatever yeah you're yeah
and these guys were not American
citizens and those were not legal
weapons they were just you know they
were Mac 10's converted to full auto
they if you have enough money you can
get anything made for you here the
talent is there these dudes weren't
dummies man they were very talented uh
very smart yeah you almost kind of have
to like admire their um hutzpah I guess
if you want to call it that they were
crazy but they wer stupid and they had a
lot of money and I was going to say like
at the beginning like some of the dudes
cuz they kind of at the beginning of the
documentary they mostly focus on um that
uh the one guy what was his name I have
it like written down right here but um
the couple of the drug smugglers you
know what I mean and um they were kind
of like making it sound kind of cool
well see CU I was going to say that we
didn't we do a review on we did on the
series the series it was like a six-part
series which is the same director um but
it was called Cocaine Cowboys the kings
of Miami that came out in 2021 and that
kind of mostly focused on a couple of
the Smugglers and [__] like that and I
will say that that series I don't know
if I said this during our review of it
because I'm pretty sure we reviewed it
but um I was like I almost kind of felt
like it some of the episodes like kind
of glamorized it because like a few
times I'm sitting there going man I'm
going to start [__] smuggling cocaine
holy [__] they just like they had so
much money they just didn't even oh yeah
we buried it at this house and we just
forgot about like we had 5 million over
there we just forgot about it you know
what I mean and like people are brenting
the house years later like hey why is
there $5 million in the Attic you know
what I mean it was like that kind of
[__] I will say that this documentary
like at the beginning it does kind of
start out talking with the Smugglers and
it's like oh it sounds pretty cool and
it's like yeah we were at the nightclubs
like buying Don per and Yan for like
random tables and [__] like that
dropping thousands and thousands of
dollars and it was like nothing because
they didn't even know how much [__]
money they had yeah it didn't but then
but then it very quickly goes into all
of the organized crime [__] happening
and all of the murders and like I said
if you are squeamish at all about crime
scene photos um this is probably not the
documentary for you because it'll show
the guy's dead
[__] face yeah like yeah you
basically see like up close and personal
like in full livid color people that
have just been like [__] riddled with
bullets and look like swiss cheese the
one dude that got like cut up and put in
a duffel bag yeah and his he's all
stacked up he's all like St like his
head's over here like it's pretty [__]
up it's pretty [__] up so I said so
this if at the beginning you were like
man I want to smug all some cocaine
that's I want all that money and [__]
like that and then after that you're
like yeah no I don't want to smoke
cocaine anymore yeah what happened was
that's terrible so much money cocaine
was worth so much money that between the
smuggling families it was worth it to
steal somebody else's shipment it was
worth enough money so they started doing
that and Wars broke out yeah they're
like you know we can just steal their
[__] and they were building armored car
dressed up to look like a [__] party
fun what was it called the party fun van
it Happy Time party something suppli
something to supply it was an armored
car and they just went to a mall the D
land mall and just like shot it up cuz
they were just trying to like kill one
dude or two dudes they didn't give a
[__] well that's what I mean when like
the Colombians got involved in anything
like that they didn't really give a [__]
if innocent people got killed in the
crossfire they just like they liked that
well we're just going to like we need to
rub out this one guy and they usually
would do it in public so they would just
like go to a mall or like a store or
something like that and just [__]
spray the dude with bullets and they
didn't care if anybody else got they
would order hits done in [__] in
airports of all things they like no man
you want to get away with it they would
just do it in airports they they real
high Vis visibility areas they'd have it
done um yeah that one guy got like
bayonetted yeah bayonetted him in an
airport and and this assassin got caught
I mean he got caught but but dude did it
yeah they were kind of Knuckleheads they
thought they could get away with
anything um the kind of crash dummies
Crash Test Dummies you know uh they
thought they were still in Colombia I
think it's part of the reason oh well we
got away with it in Colombia we could do
it here right that was you know but no
some of them did I'm not going to lie
sometimes they did get away with and
like I said cuz some of the cops are on
the take like some of the cops would
help the Smugglers out yeah like they
were on the payroll you know what I mean
like that and a lot cop cars coming up
helping and helping unload drugs right
because they would like you know they
would they break them off something like
and in other series they talk about
they'd [__] lock a drug dealer up a
high high-end drug dealer and the he
would mysteriously be released from
prison but you know the prison still
says they have him and he's still making
roll call every day yeah but he's not in
there D's been free for years running
around it's just crazy right Z said the
most chilling part to me is when the
cartel guy talks about killing his
friend's wife yeah that was [__] up
because they both went to jail right and
then um gel Blanco who was the Godmother
she paid his bail ry's bail to get him
out but she's like well your friend I
didn't authorize that so he that's on
you like I'm I'm not paying for his
[__] bail but then meanwhile that
dude who was still in jail like his wife
right was like blabbing like if you
don't let him out I'm going to go to the
FBI and I'm going to like Nar him which
is a dumb thing to say I know why she
said said that why would she say that
they killed her well the thing about it
though is that I will say I mean they
just [__] he fought he [__] shot
her in the back of the head just like in
a car she knew it was coming yeah stupid
and she was just kind of like well if
you're going to shoot me just [__] do
it right here you know what I mean I was
like it's that's kind of ballsy yeah but
I mean I guess she knew what the
consequences were I kind of think that
he she thought he wouldn't do it because
he was friends with her husband and he
he did have a hard time with it
but he did it anyway because they paid
him to do it because they're like she's
going to like n on us and we're going to
in trouble being an ex professional
Soldier I got to say dude was that he
was he was a good assassin he was I know
it's a [__] up thing to say he was a
really interesting charact he's in
prison now obviously and he's never
getting out yeah now he's got life he
killed so many people he killed like a
lot of people but he was just a regular
guy um he he did get a lot of training
from ex-military guys who helped him
he was actually a very intelligent guy
and pretty thoughtful
insightful he kind of got over that
barrier of killing people though yeah
because it did bother him at first it
bothered him for a while but then after
you did did it a lot of times he says it
was it got a lot easier just business he
said just business this is what they're
doing see he's just a very nothing
personal yeah yeah so uh I kind of
admired his ability to kind of put his
feelings down I'm kind of a Hot Blooded
guy myself personally you know I mean I
got to be mad he didn't even have to be
mad he just it was just analytical well
she's going to go she's going to go
please I like her but she's got to go
that's his best friend's wife yeah his
best friend he but like I said he felt
bad about it like cuz she you know
Griselle de Blanco she ordered the hit
yeah CU like cuz she's just going to
blab and he was kind of like well I mean
he was high enough up that it seemed
like if there was something he didn't
want to do grisela didn't get up in his
grill about it like he'd be like yeah
man I don't want to do that and she
would just get somebody else like the
like the one that the guy that they that
she particularly wanted taken out in the
airport cuz he was like he's like I'll
do it outside the airport I'm not going
in the airport that's a suicide mission
she's like no no it has to be done in
the airport and I want it done with a
Bayonet because it's like cuz he's a pig
and I want him killed like a pig Stu
like a pig yeah and so um so he's like
no I'm not doing that but he did go with
the guy that did it you know what I mean
but the guy that did it got caught he
didn't get caught he got caught later
I'm going plug it again this is the
movie Cocaine Cowboys it's got a mini
uzi with uh made out of cocaine on on it
that's the that's a goodan yeah Zan said
that was a Mac 10 made out of cocaine no
that's a mini uzi Uzi
pistol but that's the one yeah I mean
the thing about it like I said I I
remember I grew up in Florida a lot of
this happened when I was still kind of a
kid like I was aware of it cuz you'd see
it on the news and [__] like that cuz
they' be like holy crap like the [__]
crime in Miami is just like off the
chain and it was just
all like I said it was just the the
murder rate like went up how many 100%
or something like that like just in one
year like after this whole Like Cocaine
thing started because initially Miami
was well the drug smuggling started out
as marijuana right like in the 60s and
stuff and then they said it got to a
point where you know that was kind of
what we were doing for a while but the
market got flooded like there was so
much marijuana
it's like you couldn't [__] Give It
Away there was so much of it and it was
like so cheap you said you just find
huge bales of it washing up on yeah they
called it Square groupers yeah cuz it
wasn't worth anything and because it
wasn't worth anything because you
couldn't really sell it for much on the
street because it was just like I said
the market was oversaturated so they're
like at that point that's when cocaine
started getting big because it had like
a much higher street value and you
didn't need as much of it you know what
I mean like concentrated yeah and it's
like look if you're going to get busted
for marijuana anyway cuz that was
illegal at the time obviously like you
might as well go for like the higher
value [__] you know what I mean you guys
have never done cocaine cocaine is a
wonderful drug it'll turn you instantly
into an [__] you'll just get you be
talking that that kind of explains the
entirety of the 80s yeah mouth starts
running that's why Everyone's an [__]
at
the they're all [__] coked up
longterm effects is uh you become
[__] paranoid and and [__] you
sell all your possessions to to get some
it will [__] you up i' I've only done
it I've only done it for free I've never
bought any of it people had to give it
to me I would never buy it was expensive
back in the day that was like that was
almost kind of like the rich [__]
drug yes Rich [__] drug that was the
rich clubbing people drug I could never
four is if you were drinking heavily
during a club or a party you could snort
a few lines of that and you would
instantly sober up and you could start
drinking some more but you wouldn't shut
the [__] up you'd [__] talk at a mill
million miles an hour on the [__] I've
never [__] I never snored any of it
when I was sober always when I was drunk
so it it was a real good way to
counteract alcohol yeah that's that's
that's that's what we used it for I
can't imagine um like you being really
coked up because you already talk a lot
so it's just kind of like so I can't
imagine like coked up Tom like I said we
I we're getting in trouble but it's like
we've done it once but it wasn't great
it was wasn't really that effective
somebody gave us up it was some somebody
gave us some and it wasn't really all
that it wasn't really all that great so
um so I've never really seen him like on
the good [__] you know what I mean yeah
cuz that was like before I met him but I
can't
imagine man I can't imagine what a coked
up Tom would be like that would you
would just be like [__] yeah you like
I said you already talk a lot so no I
don't yeah you do so I can't so I can't
even imagine I can't even imagine but
yeah so yeah so I feel like the 80s so
here's the thing so when the [__] first
started happening when all of this drug
money started flooding into Miami and
the reason it was Miami was because it's
a great Port I mean the Pirates used it
for that reason um and at that time
before Miami was like a big huge City
that it is now um there was a lot of
these little islands and inlets and all
this other kind of [__] and a lot of it
like wasn't monitored you know what I
mean you could just they weren't sure
quite how many islands there were yeah
well because yeah I don't know if you
know but Florida is just kind of like we
got like there's little [__] islands
like all over the [__] they're just
everywhere like even little tiny ones
and [__] like that so you know so
Pirates and [__] like that would come in
there so drug smugglers would do that
too because a lot of it was not
monitored a lot of people didn't know
about it these islands were like [__]
tiny and it was like a really easy way
to get everything into the country right
because no one was like looking and if
you had like a little plane or a little
boat or something like that no one would
see you it's not like anyone's like
[__] monitoring they were flying
underneath the radar too right yeah so
when they started doing that and then
when the cocaine trade started getting
really big suddenly they noticed that um
all of these other and this is this is
crazy I don't think and I think somebody
mentioned this earlier the Miami that we
know today absolutely would not exist
had the cocaine thing not happened
you're right when like said when I say
Co the Miami Skyland was built on
cocaine I'm not lying it was it
immediately like of these they're like
there there's this huge like nightlife
culture that grw up like all these like
really fancy nightclubs and all this
kind of [__] all these Banks sprung up
like to help launder the money and [__]
like that um all of these like high-end
like luxury Brands like showed up
because all of these drug dealers had
cars more money than they could than
they knew what to do with so it's like
they're buying Rolexes they're buying
sports cars they're buying so all of
these businesses escorts yeah like
luxury businesses came to Miami and it
just they built all of that [__] just in
a really a lot of your like Top Model
type chicks were going down there to
become escorts at these [__] at these
[__] super high big like fancy
nightclubs Stu night clubs that where
the drug dealers hung out you know I
mean for [__] $20,000 nights and [__]
like that that's what they were doing
down there so people were like rushing
down there because that's where all the
money was yeah and here's the here's the
weird thing all those clubs are gone
they're all gone now I mean the weird
thing about it is that after all of that
happened and then after you know the and
everything like that started cracking
down like on the drug trade and so a lot
of them were like [__] this and a lot of
them moved out to LA or to other places
and so a lot of the luxury businesses
left Miami but
nowadays Miami seems to have jump like
come back yeah because if you go to
Miami now it's all like luxury Brands
and nightclubs and everything like that
again it got its name it Miami got put
on the map because of this era and those
drug dealers yeah without them it never
would have got the notoriety now so now
it has some now you have international
notoriety got people legendary Rich
Arabs from Dubai buying [__] in Miami
and having [__] luxury [__]
apartments and [__] down there because
you Miami's nice it's very nice you
could pull up to your own house in a
boat in certain places in Miami yeah
it's like super fancy [__] super
fancy so a lot of that was it got
kickstarted by the drug trade yeah and
it kind of went still going on but not
as big as it was no it's not like it was
back in the 80s not like not probably
what's happening now over there [__]
like in terms of illicit [__]
prostitution there's probably a lot of
that oh I imagine yeah yeah [__] uh
es high-end escorting and stuff I mean
the thing like I said I've only been to
Miami a couple of times but it does kind
of seem like Miami is kind of one of
those cities where it's like you know
there's the parts of the town that
aren't that great and [__] like that I
don't think it's anywhere near as bad as
it was in the 80s because the crime in
Miami it was like it had the highest
murder rate of the country for a while
didn't it because of the cocaine Wars
here's the weird thing it didn't it
didn't impact Americans very much though
it was all Colombians killing each other
and they were all illegal aliens they
weren't Americans well now some people
were getting killed in the crossfire
obviously yeah but it didn't impact it
statistically mostly it was it was
Colombians killing Colombians yeah like
it was all drug wars they were you know
then and a lot of times too I will admit
that even some of the quote unquote
innocent people that got killed in CR
were also involved somehow but they you
know they weren't targeted for death
they just happened to be sitting at the
same table at the person that was and
they're just like ah well it's easier to
just kill six people instead of just the
one that we're looking for you know they
were in the trade they just weren't
being targeted right I mean
it's it's like I said the guy rivy that
they talk to and there's there extensive
like interviews with him on there like I
said he's in prison he's not getting out
um but him just like talking about all
the assassinations that he did he
doesn't seem it's interesting because he
doesn't seem it's not like because
remember we talked about like the Iceman
like we did a show about the Iceman MH
who just seemed like super cold blood
and everything like that this guy no
he's a nice guy it's not yeah it doesn't
seem quite the same yeah it's like
obviously he's not a nice guy cuz he
killed a bunch of people but he doesn't
seem like he just was doing like he was
enjoying it or he was just like it was
just a job I'm yeah I'm going to call
him a nice guy okay uh he's a nice guy
but he was assassin yeah and if his
chain of command there's a lot of
soldiers that are nice guys that'll kill
you based upon what chant of command
says if his chant of command said you
had to die he killed you okay but it was
just business he had it
compartmentalized yeah he was the kind
of guy he was wife and kids and
everything yeah he was the kind of guy
you could trust around your kids and you
know what I mean and [__] you say hey
man let's go down let's go down the
store and get some milk you know he's
not [__] you he's not he's not a [__]
you know a raving lunatic yeah he's a
regular guy um but his job was just to
go job was people out when he was asking
yeah when when the when the and
sometimes he said no I will admit you
can't do that sometimes he would say
yeah I'm not going to do that right so
he was you
know may being an ex infantry I I
considered him considered him to be a
professional
Soldier but he wasn't serving a nation
state he was serving in a criminal
organization right Boba Fett we're
talking about Boba Fett basically yeah
yeah she kind of L like Boba Fett too
yeah they talked about Grisel de Blanco
like quite a bit and she well she went
to prison eventually I think they caught
up with her well because she moved her
operations out to LA because there was
too much heat on it in Miami and then
she eventually got arrested and put in
prison and I think like after she got
out of prison she got gunned down too
like in front of somebody mentioned I
think Danny said that she got a gun down
in front of a butcher or something yeah
which is funny is you think that uh uh
you know I grew up partially in Brazil
I'm [__] a big fan of Central and
South America speak
Portuguese uh I love the C
culture uh Latinos are tough they're
tough people but
they're I would say emotional is trying
to you know they're they're people of
passion okay they have a reputation for
being machismo you know [__]
Macho it is kind of a male
dominated Society yeah but that doesn't
preclude females their females are kind
of [__] high tasked in a certain way
as some of them somebody said mentioned
that earlier yeah their females are kind
of their females can get very violent uh
some of the some of the girls that are
involved in the Mexican drug trade do
all kinds of weird [__] [__] where
they're doing Satanic rituals and having
sex with the dead bodies of the guys
that they've assassinated there's all
kinds of weird Satan
IC [__] going on with Mexican cartel
female girls you know who are assassins
there's it's a
different it's a different [__]
culture okay um but you would think that
there wouldn't be any female cartel
leaders but there are yeah there are
yeah and she was like one of the worst
ones they were scared of her they think
that she may have been responsible for
as many as 200 murders yeah she didn't
she would do them herself if she had to
but she usually farmed him out but yeah
and I'm kind of listening to her story
and
I'm I'm kind of vibing on her a little
bit she was not a pretty woman but I
could tell she wanted to be a pretty
girl you notice that I could tell that
she kind of she wanted to have power she
wanted to be she I think she was jealous
of women that were better looking than
her cuz she killed one of them well yeah
she did for that for just like a pretty
pretty minor infraction pretty yeah
pretty minor infraction and it cuz that
girl was pretty which man you don't want
to piss off women man if they have the
power of life and death over people they
could be [__] man that's what I mean
it's like gener okay generally like I
said serial killers are overwhelmingly
men right like so you know and criminals
are I feel like overwhelmingly manad
violent criminals um so there is like
likely something to that I think women
are a lot um it's a lot less likely for
them to be violent or Psychopaths or
anything like that however
I will say that um we absolutely do have
that capacity in us and a lot of times
if you make us really mad we will do way
more [__] up [__] than a dude would
way more I'm watching the movie and I'm
going man [__] I'd like to meet that
women that woman and I like no probably
wouldn't no probably not that chick
could probably [__] all of a sudden
fix a on me and then she likes me and
all of a sudden I can't walk away and
then she kill she tried to kill me that
well yeah you do something you look at
her sideways look at her sideways and
she might go oh I like him I love him
and then all of a sudden oh wait you
don't love me I'll kill him so you know
yeah then she'll just have you [__]
yeah have to kill him and cut up and put
in a duffel bag and I don't want that to
happen yeah he didn't he didn't love
me that's what I mean that absolutely
would have happened yeah probably that
[__] was crazy yeah I mean she's dead
now so she can't get me but you know
what I mean I'm kind of scared of her
too to be honest with you but um
everybody was terrified of her yeah well
and it's funny because they kind of said
in the thing I can't remember who it was
that said it but they said you know in
uh Latin culture it's like it's very
male dominated like this like crime and
everything like that so it's like for
her to have risen to that position of
power she had to be really [__] mean
well not either that or very beautiful
or a mixture of the two because you know
it goes way back in even Spanish and
castian culture you know you had Queen
Isabella was evidently [__] extremely
gorgeous and could [__] get men to do
anything for her you know what I mean so
there's there's just
that thing you know what I mean like
you're my queen and I love you was not
beautiful though no no she was just
terrified so she was probably just like
really terrifying and yeah Zan said she
had a lot of Charisma to have all those
men following her killing she must have
because like I said they were all
terrified of her and rivy I don't he
never betrayed her now some people did
but they got very quickly killed but I'd
be like you'd be really stupid to like
[__] her over cuz man you stole like a
little bit of money from her or did one
little bitty thing didn't like she would
absolutely have you killed you know what
I mean so but rivy Ry was lucky that he
didn't have to service her although
maybe he did yeah he didn't bring that
up he didn't bring that up but he might
have had to yeah I would think maybe
that was part of his job description
yeah that didn't really occur to me
until now but I'm like yeah that would
totally make sense because that would
make sense in in criminal hierarchies
that she owns
him
yeah cuz it would work the same the
other way around yeah yeah so you would
think that if she had gotten to that
position of power and basically had the
bit you know she had the power of life
and death over everybody in the
organization like I said you just you
said a wrong thing yeah and she would
absolutely was Gooding guy he was yeah
good and I would think that she'd be
like oh tonight you tonight you're with
me she would say some [__] like that she
probably wouldn't stop him from having
girlfriends and [__] and relation but
and you'd be terrified to say no I tell
you that tonight tonight you're with me
that's that's kind of the [__] she would
do probably oh my God it never didn't
mention
uh well she wasn't ugly she was just she
was she was just kind of like average
looking like she yeah right because they
showed her well they showed her when she
was younger but a lot of the pictures
that she she was kind of middle-aged
right um you know and you could tell
that she was trying to be like
fashionable and stuff cuz she always had
like fantastic outfit she was trying to
be very pretty right but you could tell
that she was like real mad about yeah
you also tell that she really kind of
came from nothing she had terrible taste
yeah mean what she's wearing is all
wrong for 80
United States Miami it's kind of like a
a foreigner a poor Foreigner's concept
of what what a rich girl would look like
she yeah she's not cuz that's kind of
the thing it's like if you did poor
people yeah grow up rich you can't I
feel like you can't
really you can't really blend in with
that it doesn't look the same doesn't
look the same look she
looked it was forced she trying to look
rich I get what you're saying yeah yeah
Zan said um Latinas will definitely
fight you yeah I grew up around him well
like I said it's a it's a passionate
culture all around you know what I mean
it's very gendered and uh it's good
though I liked it it's the way it's
supposed to be if you ask me I think I
think they're on to something I like it
that's how I grew up I understand it I
but I know the dramatic side of it too
more rational cool be control of your
emotions you know more
I'm kind of I'm more like that she's
like that she's very gtic but I kind of
like I can go either way depending on
the situ but I get it I get it because I
you know I don't know if you know I'm
I'm not entirely Spock like well no in a
way I think I am Spock like because I
think people think Spock didn't have any
emotions but he did he was controlling
them Vulcans had like heightened
emotions but over the years they had
learned to control them and I think I'm
more like that so that's why I think
that I'm kind of more similar to spock
cuz I do feel like very deeply and [__]
like that but it's just I try not to
like overreact to [__] that's a very uh
Germanic uh very um uh uh [__]
Protestant way of doing things that's
what it is I'm just like I don't you
know I don't know Latinos are Catholic
it's it's about emotion and style I get
it yeah I get it I do yeah I get it yeah
and I do have a little bit of that but
it's just kind of like I feel like
mostly I'm the other way but I'm just
I've always been like that I think it's
genetic cuz I can't I can't remember
being any other I think the religious
cultures are are actually created by the
genetic differences if you ask me I
think I think and then the cultures
reinforce it genetically after in in the
natural selection process you know what
I mean so yeah genes and cultures go
hand in hand yeah but I understand both
ways yeah I understand both ways and I
mean you've been with me a long time you
know that I'm kind of now I will get AB
I can bring it out of you though oh yeah
I will get absolutely mad about [__] it
is in there I'm not saying that um I'll
get like really [__] I'll go off on a
tear I'm not I'm not saying that but
most of the time I mostly keep my [__]
together I feel like yeah I'm pretty I
can get her sexy though too I get her
talk I get her talking dirty and then it
[__] [__] comes out or something
that's what I'm saying it's in there
this comes it's in there I love to see
it love to watch it it's in there and I
think I think that you like it more
because I don't do it all the time yeah
so it's more like kind of like you just
get to see it every now and then and
you're just like oh yeah you know what I
mean so it's kind of like that you keep
talking cuz I'm pretty I'm pretty Spock
like usually yeah but yeah well I think
well see I think that's why like a lot
of women like crushed on Spock because
he was like that most of the time but
then when you had that at one episode
like when he was going through Pon far
or or something or when he was evil
Spock or something like that it was like
oh yeah you know what I mean so it's
kind of like that kind of situation I
feel like he wasn't really evil Spock in
the mirror episode well you know what I
mean he was more like third world Spock
yeah you know he was in developing
developing country Spock you know low
low trust low trust Society Spock yeah
yeah yeah um yeah Tammy said Grisel the
blancco ghost is gonna come get me yeah
bring it there [__] ghosts they're
not gonna come get me yeah Zan said I'm
so happy you guys like this one yeah
this was like a lot of yeah we had a
great time like s there watching this I
was just I want to go back and see the
television series again yeah cuz that
that was good too like I said we
reviewed it while back yeah Timmy says
they say Cleopatra wasn't really all
that good-looking either yeah that's
true they do um she just had personality
smarts and Charisma yeah she um she's
supposed to be very intelligent very
educated yeah and it's like if the coins
they made of her are any
indication um I wouldn't call her ugly
necessarily but she was kind of she was
a little bit homely a little bit but see
that's the thing like you don't know
like you just see this rendering of her
that was done on a coin that was
probably
you know maybe better but the thing
about it is you don't see her in real
life here's the thing like moving around
and talking and stuff here's the thing
about
cleopa she she was a tmy she was not
Egyptian cleop panta yeah cleopa cleopa
was not she was not even Egyptian
there's a lot of people you know say
well she's Egyptian and it portray she
wasn't though she wasn't Egyptian she's
she she was a Greek yeah and the Greeks
were given control over over the the
Greek tmy family was given control over
Egypt by Rome because they were part of
the Roman Empire and as as a gift to to
this [__] powerful Greek family they
gave them control over Egypt so she was
not an Egyptian and she had nothing to
do with those damn pyramids that she
lived a long time after
that but
um Julius who ended up and Mark Anthony
they both hooked up to her both hook up
both hooked up with her Julius Caesar um
um said she wasn't good-looking but that
she was very magnetic he he liked her
yeah he had a kid with her and then
tmy not Tom what's his name Mark Anthony
Mark
Anthony ran off with her during a civil
war they both got killed of course you
know yeah every story but see that just
goes to show that looks and sexiness or
magnetism are two different things well
she was never she was never said to be
ugly but they said that she was very
magnetic attractive very attractive but
I think it was her intelligence and her
power and she did some ballsy [__] a lot
of ballsy [__] had herself wrapped up in
a carpet and smuggled in to go seek
Julius they rolled her
out got past your security [__] and
then she's coming on and [__] made
move that is pretty badass yeah made a
move
on she probably was very interesting
well like I said she must have been
because like people seem like obsessed
with her and Julius had his pick of the
best looking women in Roman Empire he
chose that one so yeah there was
obviously something about it like I said
so it's not necessarily like looks help
I'm not saying that yeah get you in the
door but looks and sexiness are two
different things and from julius's Point
of View CA was poor her you know the
Egyptian Province was poor at that time
it was a failed Province so it's not
like he was scoping out on a rich girl
there were girls back in Rome that were
richer but he liked her so there was
something to her yeah must have been
like I said yeah
um Danny ring said Mickey Monday sold
some great a [__] man yeah um yeah
Mickey Monday was the guy in the um one
of the drink yeah in the documentary who
he was kind of like a Florida native
like a Florida Cracker as they would
call it nowadays he was also a [__]
Ginger
yeah she's a little ginger redneck and
he had his own
plane and he started out smug I think he
started out smuggling marijuana and then
started doing cocaine because it was
like you know more lucrative I guess but
the thing about it and I was going to
mention too is that another thing that
they did like obviously they had to
launder all this money that was coming
in from somewhere so that was another
thing that kind of contributed to the
economy of Miami in general because all
these people were buying property all
over the place they were buying like
Mickey Monday had he's like he had a
hanger or like a warehouse type of stuff
where he would bring in the drugs and
he's like and I owned all of the other
warehouses around it so it's like nobody
was around there cuz I owned everything
so it's like so I could just bring in
the [__] and it's like no one was around
there to watch me so you know what I
mean cuz they had so much [__] money
it's like they didn't even think
anything about it it's like yeah we
dropped like a million dollars like on
this bigger plane and [__] like that
they had so much money they didn't even
know what to do with it it's [__]
crazy Zan said Jenny I'm going to send
you another video about the Corina
incident if that's okay yes I would like
that because that is um what we're going
to do the show about on Wednesday night
which actually I didn't even know that
much about I feel like everybody knows
about um you know the de of pass
incident but there was another similar
thing that happened in 1993 which is
usually called the Corina incident or
the um what do they call it the Kamar
Dean or whatever the mountain range is
called but it was kind of a similar
thing but kind of weirder I don't know
it was pretty weird um so that's what
we're going to do the Wednesday night
show about so you know so that would be
cool like yeah if you sent me another
video about it I went through what I
usually do after um I get the results
from the poll and see what the winning
topic was I'll usually go through and
start making notes and then I'll start
going on YouTube or wherever and like
starting to see if I can find
documentaries about it and [__] and I
put them all in a playlist so I can like
kind of watch them like while I'm doing
other things and then like take notes
you know while I'm doing so I have like
notes ready for Wednesday that's usually
what I
do yeah Griselda was a real lady
she was something else I mean like I
said and some of the [__] like some of
the killings that
she ordered
um she was just real you could tell that
she did not give one actual [__] like
if that I think that was kind of true of
like a lot of this they they really
didn't seem to care if they got caught
they didn't think they were going to get
caught I mean they were real [__]
Brazen man they would just like like
like I said they would just shoot up a
mall like in the middle of the day they
would just shoot at each other on the
[__] freeway like on [__] U on 95
or whatever um you know they would just
come up to somebody in a restaurant and
just like shoot them in the face and
just like run out and [__] like that and
they just they seem to
have no um worry that they were going to
get caught and a lot of times they
didn't because like I said a lot of the
cops and [__] like that were on the
payroll were helping them out there was
like a huge they talked about this in
the documentary too that that was like a
huge Scandal back then about all of
these I don't remember how many cops it
was it was like 70 or 80 cops that they
caught that were working with the drug
dealers and were kind of like just
either helping them transport drugs or
like looking the other way when they
were shooting people or whatever it was
just too much money yeah they because
yeah like I said they had the the drug
dealers had so much money that they
didn't even like think about it like
breaking off hey here's a million
dollars or here's this that and the
other so they could just like get away
with whatever you know it was [__]
crazy
crazy Zach says there's a huge
controversy about the mar Mami is it
Mami okay Manor haunted house um might
make a good show topic or just one about
haunted houses in general that actually
might be good I've kind of heard that
but I don't really know that much about
it so I will write that down and I will
put it in the poll you find a pie paper
that okay yeah I remember hearing about
that okay let me write this down M me
Mansion so we can maybe put that in the
poll maybe do a show about that one of
these days that would be fun people that
are into uh damn old crime american
crime stories they'll focus in on Old
Chicago and Scarface and all
that the old Italian
mob with the Irish guys that helped him
but now the Florida story has aged to
the point to where [__] man these people
are [__] actually Larger than Life
yeah they're bigger in in many ways than
say Al
Capone they did more [__] they did yeah
more money too it was a lot more money
more money more deaths more deaths yeah
I mean big time yeah it was modern
technology yeah I mean people forget
about it though I'm an American I forget
about it I live in Florida and forgot
about it yeah I mean you don't really
think about it on a day to-day basis
right like like I said I remember
hearing about it at the time but I was a
kid yeah you know and uh when I heard
when mostly when I thought of the [__]
that was going down in Miami I thought
of Don Johnson and
tubs from from the series Miami Vice
which I only saw a couple I really only
watch that sometimes yeah remember saw I
only saw a couple of episodes I think it
wasn't really a show that I watched I
liked it but it was I was a little too
young to really appreciate it and I have
to go back and see it again see if it if
it aged
well I we should do a revisit on the
Miami Vice cuz I don't remember I
remember a couple of episodes here and
there but I don't remember much about it
but like I said I'm sure it was like
super glamorized yeah but but that was
one thing that I liked about this
documentary is that it's not glamorized
at all like I said at the beginning it
kind of sounds like fun cuz the
smugglers in the early days and they're
kind of talking about yeah we started
smuggling marijuana we had all these
planes and we had all this [__] money
and we were doing this and the other
start out they weren't violent right and
it kind of started out like that but
like I said once the Colombians got
involved once the Cuban prisoners got
involved and [__] like that and people
started like just gunning people down in
Cold Blood every day um you know it kind
of became something else and the fact
that this documentary absolutely has
like a large chunk of it which shows the
crime scene photos and I'm not just
talking about hey far away like dead
body over there that's kind of like you
know uh you know blurred out or whatever
these are up close and personal [__]
like I said here's a dude that's cut up
in a duffel bag yeah there you go right
in your face yeah so yeah they're not
squeamish about it they're really not um
they didn't warn you ahead of time
either I'm like oh damn they do things
in pretty cool format when they
introduce a character they'll show like
a mug shot of him or a [__] still
photo of him and if and if if you're pay
if you're not if you're paying attention
you'll see that every now and then that
mug shot will [__] blink like that
was like so weird it was like so subtle
yeah it was real subtle like or the eyes
would kind of go like that look yeah and
I'm just like that's kind of creepy kind
of creepy that's kind of Creeper that's
kind of creepy look it was cool though
very effective like the music is great
man it's new retro wave yeah yeah that's
what they're playing except like I said
that's what's crazy it's like not really
new retro wave because it was Yan hammer
and he was the guy that did them music
from the original Miami Vice and new
retro wave is basically like ripping off
that that yeah but it was new yeah he
was doing new versions of it it was I
just thought it was cool that they got
him to do the music yeah cuz it really
gave it that yeah feel because they
really had a lot of like news footage
and stuff like that like from back in
the day so you got to see Miami like
back in the 70s and ' 80s which was
crazy yeah and it's you know that's just
like kind of cool to see even though
like I said it
doesn't it's just it's really
interesting they had this one lady on
there and I think she was what was she
like a journalist or something like that
and she was talking about you know she
lived in Miami most of her life and she
was saying that um she's like I'm not
really sure
she's like yeah the city was kind of
built on that but she's like I'm not
really sure it was worth all the Death
you know what I mean it's like we maybe
could have done that without all of that
but I don't know it's a weird place like
I said I don't think and I think a
couple people said this in the
documentary I don't know if there's any
other City quite like that that has that
same kind of History to it yeah where it
was basically like not much of any it
was like an like a small like Retirement
Community essentially yeah um and then
all these drugs started coming in and
then it became like this kind of like
rich people's Paradise but also like
this horrible cess pit of crime like
organized crime and murder and then like
it kind of went downhill for a while
like after you know they started
cracking down on the [__] like and after
a bunch of the drug dealers left but it
kind of has come back now it's kind of
seen as like Miami nowadays I feel like
it's more perceived as has like a a a
nightlife spot like that's they have
like a lot of really good clubs and
stuff like that and just kind of like
that's you go there to like rich people
go there to shop and [__] like that like
I feel like that's kind of the thing s
says Jenny I'm G to send you another
video yeah yeah yeah he was saying like
well the Corina incident that's what
we're doing the show about on Wednesday
okay which is like I said it's kind of
like the de of pass okay incident but
it's like not as many people know about
it I feel like cuz I had never heard of
it happened in the '90s but but it's
kind of similar and it's all and it's
just as weird I think if not more weird
yeah Zan said Miami is like the East
Coast Las Vegas it is kind of it's not
exactly the same but I mean because Las
Vegas was also founded on organized
crime so I guess it's sort of similar
but so there are definitely parallels
there but it's happened many times
throughout American history yeah
um I mean you go back you go back in
time to the uh 1600s 1700s New Orleans
was the center of all the [__] that's
kind of what I was thinking it's
constantly bouncing around depends on
what the situation is New Orleans was
kind of like the original Pirate
Cove although Florida was too that
probably predates that it's just another
one yeah remember we did a show about
Florida Pirates which was super fun I
got like a bunch of books about that
yeah I'm fascinated by the whole like
Florida pirate connection yeah and that
was long before there was in United
States it was still Spanish territory
then yeah well like I said Tampa they
have like a whole [__] Pirate
festival every year it's just pirate
everything yeah it's Pirates well Tampa
used to be Pirates and Cuban cigar
factories was pretty much all of it New
Orleans was all French territory yeah
they got purchased later on during The
Louisiana
Purchase but you know Pirates were all
throughout this place illegal activities
if there's something kind of loophole
where you can make money dudes are going
to try to make money through the
shipping or through shipping well
because Florida is like almost all
Coastline it's you know it's all right
on the coast essentially so you got
there's a lot of places you can smuggle
[__] you got the Atlantic and then you
got the damn Gul of Mexico G of Mexico
on either side
mhm yeah so that's why that ended up
happening why they became a drug
smuggling Hub as well but it was a
smuggling hub for everything yeah like
going back since it was [__]
discovered you know what I mean yeah
discovered everybody knew it was here
when the Europeans discovered it I meant
uh Danny says the Pennsylvania UFO
Abduction and mutilation case of Todd
se's in 2001 would make a great show
just saying and his death was blamed on
cocaine usage and resembled the infamous
cattle mutilation cases I don't remember
that I don't remember that either but I
wrote it down so I will put that in our
next cuz I saw that
earlier um Zach says I remember Miami
and Vegas were the ations to be back in
the 2000s because of
CSI maybe so I've never been to Vegas
actually doesn't really seem like my
kind of my my sister and my brother have
been there and they love it but Florida
is more popular now than it ever was the
population's booming everybody from New
York and California is moving here
[__] um yeah and this area was very
rural just a couple years ago I mean
it's just Farms now they're just
building building [__] all kinds of
housing complexes and [__] here we're
now almost we're on the outskirts of
Orlando now I mean this is still
considered an Orlando I don't know if
they'd go so far as to call it a suburb
CU yeah it's more like that cuz it's a
little far out for a suburb but it's
still considered part of the Orlando
metro area where we live before even
though we're about 28 miles away where
we Liv before in
Sanford that was considered country 10
years ago when we first when we moved
there it and then all a sudden it's now
part of Orlando we drove through there
cuz we went to memories of India over
the weekend and we drove through our old
neighborhood like you know through the
old place we used to work and they
they're building [__] everywhere like
they're building houses and yeah and it
had built up a lot like just in the 10
11 years that we lived at that house it
was rural when we first bought it I
don't know if I'd say rural but semi-
rural um but by the time we left ex yeah
by the time we left it was [__]
packed it was just like businesses
everywhere there was houses everywhere
the traffic was getting bad traffic
lights and [__] [__] yeah none of
that was there when we moved in I mean
we know this shit's getting built up
over here now where we are now because
they're building D Donuts up the [__]
road we as this is okay you guys this is
so funny so like we still kind of live
like in a like I said it's semi- rural
like we live in a neighborhood there's a
lot of houses but right across from it
there's just big farms and our
neighborhood is a golf course yeah it's
like a golf course in a restaurant and
then like bunch of houses and then
across the street there's like big ass
Farms there's all these Farms really all
farms and blue blueberries horses cattle
all that kind of stuff um I used to
[__] train horses here [__] 10
years ago there's a lot of that too
there's a lot of like course training
and that kind of stuff so the only thing
that's super close is Dollar General
like which is true of many rural
communities like the Dollar General is
literally you could walk to it it's like
right next door to the
community now up the road a little way
is kind of a strip mall and it's got a
Publix it's got a liquor store it's got
a um Japanese restaurant it's got a
which is great which is really good migi
yeah I've all over world sushi that [__]
be like from New York I've been to New
York I was really surprised that a that
a restaurant that good was in right here
this area yeah like a Japanese you don't
get much for your money but at the
quality is very good we need to go it's
slightly expensive but maybe we should
go tomorrow we'll go tomorrow but um
it's expensive but the food's really
really good yeah and um so they got that
they got there's like a hair cut place
there's like a there's like a um diner
with like a breakfast brunch place
there's a
Domino's and um so they started building
something in the parking lot and we're
looking at it and we're like that looks
like drive-through windows and we kind
of got excited because we don't have
this is crazy but we don't really have
any fast food yeah I thought going to be
a McDon that close I was I hope that's a
McDonald's I mean we have there's the
closest McDonald's is what like 8 miles
away is it 8 Miles something like that
it's up there like by that Starbucks
that you ride to all the time which is
like I said I think it's eight or nine
miles so we don't really have any fast
food that's why we always stop at Circle
K on the way home it's on the way to get
sandwiches and stuff cuz there's not any
restaurants now there is a Subway inside
the Circle C but I have never it's
always closed to the yeah it's always
like yeah but Circle K is yeah so we
just get like sandwiches and chips and
stuff like that on the way home there's
no fast food so we noticed they were
building something and I and we were
like that looks like drive-through
Windows maybe that's McDonald's and we
got like super excited yeah and it's
like maybe it'll be open 24 hours even
though a lot of them aren't nowadays
yeah but we asked the guy yeah I'm
yelling I'm say man what you he yells
out there what what are you guys
building to the guy in the hard hat yeah
it's a Dunkin Donuts and I was like well
that's good too that's good too so
they're building a Dunkin Donuts
breakfast food all day and we are just
like un I don't know why we're so
excited about it but we're excited about
it they got like breakfast sandwiches
and I was like donuts and Dunkin Donuts
got good coffee I think they got better
coffee than Starbucks I like Starbucks
coffee too but dunin Duncan's better
yeah actually to be honest like um
McDonald's coffee is better than
Starbucks also actually 7-Eleven coffee
is also better than Starbucks McDonald's
actually has the best coffee I think
they do actually but like I said
7-Eleven actually has better coffee than
you would think they have like a lot of
choices but we are very excited that
they're building a Dunkin noce isn't
that sad that we're like that's our R
this says Tu Don it's not that rural she
doesn't know how rural you should have
seen miss you should have seen no I know
I know like I said it's semi- rural SE
Mississippi yeah it's nowhere near as R
we're we're [__] only
like we're [__] 15 20 minutes away
from the outskirts of Orlando we could
be in downtown Orlando inck when we go
to Bar 40 minutes it's just which is not
in it's not downtown Orlando it's kind
of more in the warehouse District yeah
that takes us it's 28 mil miles M so it
takes about half an hour like to drive
there which is not that big a deal
nothing we're jamming the whole way to
music and [__] yeah it seems like
nothing um downtown Sanford is only
about 20 minutes away yeah this we're in
the exurbs yeah there the exerts are
still rural yeah around
Orlando you know it's horse
farms Flower Farms and food and [__]
like that yeah mostly what's around here
is horse farms blueberry farms I can go
up the road [__] I can get fresh
pumpkins and [__] pumpkin farms yeah can
get anything I want nurseries yeah like
all that kind of stuff that's like all
that's around here which is nice CU you
can kind of go and get fresh food when
you want it yeah it won't be here 10
years from now no probably not they're
going to build stuff they're going to
build stuff every build houses
everywhere cuz there is just land
everywhere up here empty land and
they're just going to build it all over
the place I do like this neighborhood
now though it is a little bit far from
[__] yeah but
well this house gained $255,000 worth of
value in the year and a half that we've
been here about a year right no I think
well maybe two almost two year and a
half I think it's been like been like
two years yeah it went up 25,000 when
did we we moved right around it was
right around my birthday right so it was
right around like late September early
October something like that so I think
it was like two years ago yeah at this
point like two years and two months or
something okay what are they saying I
can't really read it um let me
see Zach says the new uh GTA like Grand
Theft Auto game is now set in Florida as
well okay but they renamed the state to
leonida I don't know that leonida
leonida even though everybody knows well
he showed me the trailer like he SED to
me on Facebook and he's like is this
accurate and I watch the trailer and I'm
just like yeah that looked pretty
accurate it's got like people pulling
alligators out of pools and people
shooting at each other on the freeway it
was it was very it was very Flor I
should show it I know a lot of you
[__] are into porn and [__]
most of that porn you're seeing is
[__] is is shot around here most of
it yeah Florida Miami area it's just
it's a huge those those high-rise hotels
where the chicks getting banged against
the [__] damn glass and you see the
cityscape and [__] that's that's
Miami most of them are film that's Miami
yeah well actually or or Tampa or St P
or could be Tampa right yeah a lot of
times you see some fine [__] you
know she's out by the pool during the
middle of the day and [__] and then some
[__] go it's Florida if you see palm
trees in the back Florida well the one
nice thing about Florida is that you can
shoot porn Outdoors pretty much all year
round because you're not going to freeze
your your [__] off you know what I mean
and people are out working during the
day so it you can [__] find locations
during the work day to shoot porn me and
Jed do it I was going to say I be around
we should schedule some [__] for
Thursday because Thursday we should go
and like film some more outdoor [__] at
our at our spot yeah outdoor [__] is fun
to fun to shoot cuz I feel like no one
will be there although we got to watch
cuz I think a lot of kids you feeling
some outdoor [__] H trying to get some
outdoor [__] you know how much I love
that yeah okay well because I well I
feel like we have to be careful though
because I feel like the kids might be
out for Christmas break we ought to go
down we ought to go down to the [__]
Park you know which park I'm talking
about I'm not going say yeah not going
to say I'm not going to say it we got to
go with some picnic [__] that's what I'm
saying that would be super fun and we'll
have a picnic and [__] we'll shoot
some porn as we'll break some toys with
us and some cameras yeah that'd be super
fun okay all right we can do that I like
that Park yeah it's really big and
there's there's sections of it where
like where no one's around like there's
sections of it dock that goes over the
[__] Lake fing M and [__] [__]
yeah yeah it's like uh you guys can see
that we shot some stuff there this is a
plug I did do one video
at that Park yeah just like sitting on
yeah the bench on the bench out on the
dock like like I said like just out in
the open like it was just like and there
was like a bunch of houses across the
thing just like right there by the dock
or whatever but nobody was there yeah I
mean there were people there at the park
but they were and that is on Mini vids
over in the other section mini vids 13
cam spell it out 13 cam on Mini vids and
you'll find it Zach says oh God Jenny
what if your siblings find your other
content um they all know they already
know yeah they all know so I don't think
they would look for it we were all
talking about we were in Disney talking
about it yeah Downtown Disney we went
and had lunch with my sister and my
sister-in-law yeah they were like they
were they were almost interested oh and
they were just kind of like oh okay yeah
yeah yeah that sounds like I said my
siblings are like me but yeah yeah
younger and one and two of them are
different gender but other than that
we're like very very similar so you tell
them like yeah and all the people
married are [__] cool so yeah so I'm
just like sitting there like I just said
yeah we're doing this and they're like
oh okay yeah like they didn't really
think anything they think and it's like
it's not like they're going to go look
because I was just kind of like well if
my siblings were doing it I probably
wouldn't go look for it because that
would be weird but it's just kind of
like you know what I mean so I wasn't
I'm not embarrassed about it so I just
you know I just thought it was kind of
funny but yeah they don't I show it to
one of my Army buddies they all know
showed one of my Army buddies from
[__] what one did what one did you
show uh no I just showed him some of
some of the stuff photos and [__] from
it not thing he's said God man she's
[__] hot I said she's 51 she go no
[__] and I was like yeah that was my boy
from the rec too I was wondering show me
what pictures you sent cuz I'm curious
uh it's okay yeah I'll show you
later they were just no they were just
nice photos from the uh that you took oh
okay yeah you know what I mean the
Selfies and Sh that I took with the ring
light and stuff like that okay I did
take a lot of phot Stu like that yeah um
just like mostly just topless photos oh
okay that's fine like I said I'm not I'm
not bothered I don't I don't wonder I
was just kind of like do I look good in
those let's
see cuz sometimes you were you kind of
like like photos that I don't like and
sometimes he'll send photos to people
and I'm just like I I don't really like
and guys are I'm very hard on myself
guys like [__] that sometimes women
don't like I'm that's a great photo of
you oh no I look terrible and I'm just
like ah yeah I know but it's a whole
thing d said don't diss Dunkin Donuts I
never would you know they have great
iced coffee I they I agree um Dunkin
Donuts I think has I don't know if I'd
say they have the best coffee but it's
definitely like in the top three better
than Starbucks for sure I think
McDonald's has the best coffee but
Dunkin Donuts might be
second and I haven't had Dunkin Donuts
donuts in a long time this is probably
bad that we have a Dunkin Donuts opening
up the street I'm going to get fat I'm
going to gain like like 200 lb I love
[__] Donuts well see that's why I
don't go get them because I'm just like
man I'm going to go get some donuts and
I'm going to eat a whole [__] dozen
because I will but um you know I haven't
had them in a long time I don't think
Dunkin Donuts is as good as Crispy Cream
but I don't know they're they're kind of
a little bit
different but I don't know I'm excited I
don't think I've ever had any of Dunkin'
Donuts breakfast sandwiches but I've
heard that some of them are good and
maybe they have them all day which is a
plus we'll see I don't know like I said
we are just inordinately excited about
that opening cuz like I said we don't
have any fast food around here
nothing all we have is like sit down
restaurants we have a dominoes but
that's not really fast food [__]
dominoes yeah like it's good in a pinch
if you have to oh and there's a Chinese
restaurant down there too like a Chinese
takeout yeah but it's not that great
either it's okay it's okay um we've
gotten takeout from there multiple times
and it's pretty good it's about you a
lot but it's about standard standard
it's about standard
it's a good deal because you get a lot
of food for not a lot a lot of money
which is another thing like we ate at
memories of India this past weekend
which we hadn't been there I don't
remember the last time we went there
when was the last time we went there
where memories of India oh long time ago
we went last time it was just a couple
days ago but I know but I'm just saying
before that long time because you were
talking around on the show and then like
on Saturday he was like well let's go to
the Chinese place I'm like oh you were
talking about memories of India let's go
to memories of India I'm kind of like
excited about that and we haven't been
there for a long time and there was like
nobody in there it was like Saturday
lunchtime and it was dead and I was like
what the [__] food was good though but
the food was like really good I got lamb
cormet it's just like and another thing
too is I forgot how much [__] food
you get it's a good deal yeah a good
deal like like I said it comes with naan
um it comes with like all the dips and
everything like that comes with a Samosa
and it comes with dessert yeah Rita for
what like 18 19 bucks it cheap I was
like that was cheap it was 35 altogether
for both of us for two people for two
people Danny's telling me what to wear
he wants me to wear the Omega Man shirt
tomorrow if I wear what you want me to
wear tomorrow then people might think
then that means I may be your [__] no
one will know only Danny will know only
Dan will know well and I'll know
obviously we'll
see and I might tell it everybody you
never
know no I'm just there's no telling what
I'll wear Ben says the public indecency
series yeah I don't know there's
something kind of fun about it like I
said I don't want to get caught but cuz
that would be embarrassing but it's like
the well here they wouldn't care no I
don't think they would care they just be
like hey what is like oh you guys make
creating content yeah like yeah no the
cops here are cool actually probably
they'd be like hey we make content here
to yeah yeah we make content here all
cont you
know Danny says Burger King's ice mocha
coffee is legit huh I don't think I've
ever gotten coffee at Burger King we
used to go to Burger King every now and
then like because it was on the way to
the movie theater but I don't think I
ever got coffee in there maybe I should
yeah Zan said the donuts aren't as good
as Crispy Cream yeah I agree but they
are still good well I got Duncan does
have good breakfast sandwiches yeah but
Duncan has more more choice on [__]
that's true like crispy K cream their
kind of main thing is their original
thing no well no they have other kinds
too but the original one frosting with
the CH is is the best one I mean that's
the OG but you know Dunkin Donuts has
all kinds of cake vers cake Donuts they
got all kind of crazy [__] they got all
kinds of crazy [__] they got muffins
they got [__] Bagels yeah
Bagels so I I I take [__] Duncan over
over [__] um say Starbucks any day I
used to go to Starbucks I'm thinking I
might divert and just do St uh [__]
Dunkin' Donuts it's closer now well it's
yeah it's just right up the street but
then I have to [__] get a ride out of
this somehow so I'll just go some
somewhere else after I don't know that's
what I mean cuz like well yeah cuz I
mean you usually just go out on the bike
for a ride for the ride and you just end
up at Starbucks cuz it was kind of just
like up yeah it's my turnaround Point
yeah
yeah yeah so they did say they have good
breakfast sandwich I've never had a
breakfast sandwich at Duncan but I have
heard that they're good and Zan said
they have a Texas toast breakfast
sandwich that's amazing okay I'm going
check it out once they once they're up
and roll I'm going come in there and
make myself known I went down make
myself known I went down to liquor store
on Friday afternoon I think or Thursday
and I was like looking at the progress
and they are that [__] looks almost
finished does it I don't know how much
longer it's going to take before they
open but they're working on it pretty
fast tell you one thing if Duncan's
moving in there next to it more shit's
going to move it's going to go cuz
there's a big empty lot yeah there's
going to be uh McDonald's there probably
cuz like I said we do need some more I'm
not there isn't a McDonald's around
there's not yeah the closest McDonald's
is up where that past where that
Starbucks is like I said I think it's
eight or N9 10 miles you see they built
housing complexes around here condos
expensive condos yeah so there's going
to be more corporate [__] here appearing
soon I kind of wish they would because I
want more got we got a Walgreens we got
a [__] all this and that it's a CVS
actually it's a CVS we got a [__]
Publix which is [__] great I love
that Publix if you're hungry you can go
to Publix and get you a [__] whole
chicken for like seven eight bucks or
one of their subs which
the bests anywhere I I would submit some
of the best subs they [__] blow their
[__] Subs are amazing blow a [__]
Boston sub or grinder whatever they call
them out of the [__] water publ are
kind of I feel like they're known for
their subs their subs are their ice
cream is [__] great oh [__] we just
got like so we don't usually buy ice
cream cuz like I said we don't have a
lot of junk food in the house other than
like the occasional Little Debbie cuz
like I said we'll get fat but other day
we were at Publix buying some other [__]
[__] and they had a deal on the Publix's
brand ice cream two for $9 yeah and I
was like o That's super cheap because I
was going to say the Blue Bell which is
also good was like $9 just for one yeah
so the fact that they had two for n the
Publix brand I was just like oh man so
we got mint chocolate pie pumpkin pie oh
man and mint chocolate chip and holy
[__] that pumpkin pie ice cream tasted
exactly like a p like a pkin pie crust
and everything it had pieces of crust in
everything man has their own crey they
are making that they're not buying that
they're making that they said that they
had were going to have peppermint stick
but it was all sold out when I cuz
that's my favorite holiday flavor is
peti but the mint chocolate chip was
also delicious I also want some coffee
over the years I over the years I have
become a [__] a loyal Public's
[__] follower the the quality of
their [__] store brands rules [__]
great yeah every single like store brand
that I bought from them has
better than name brand yeah a lot of
times cheaper yeah yeah I will not
hesitate to buy like a Publix brand
anything because all their [__] is like
really good juice
fruit ice cream everything tomato sauce
Tom sauce anything anything that they
has their brand name on it is better
than the [__] and they don't have a
thing where it's just I mean basically
they don't have like a brand name it's
just like Publix it just has the Publix
logo on it yeah yeah and then it's their
version of it and it's like like I said
I don't think I've ever got a Publix
brand anything that was bad it was all
good all better than stock [__] than the
name brand better than name
brand yeah and their ice cream is super
good say ice cream is [__] great it's
almost as good as Blue
Bell as good yeah maybe as good as blue
I haven't had Blue Bell in a long time
but yeah that that pumpkin pie ice cream
that was legit that tasted just like a
[__] pumpkin pie it was like super
rich and like I said it had these big
chunks of like pumpkin pie crust in it
oh man it was like really good we just
finished it off last night actually
um Danny says Dunkin Donuts should
recycle their stale Donuts into bread
pudding instead of wasting the donuts
they probably should I don't know why I
don't really like bread pudding all that
much but yeah they should probably do
that they should probably do that yeah
Burger King started in Miami that's
right they did uh Zan said Starbucks
sucks um Starbucks is good for some
things I do like their like their
regular coffee is not not the best um
but I do like their Frappuccinos and
like their seasonal kind of stuff is
usually good like they're good if you
just want like essentially like a coffee
milkshake they're good for that but to
be honest we usually go to like Tom goes
to Starbucks a lot because it's just
like on his ride so he'll go there and
they have Wi-Fi so he can go there and
fart around on his tablet for a while or
whatever get out of the house but on the
weekends we usually go to books a
million which has another coffee shop
shop in it which is called Joe mugs and
they usually have they have similar
stuff to what Starbucks has um you know
they have Frappuccino to they don't call
them that obviously because it's a
Starbucks thing I think they just call
him a frappe but um some of their shit's
real good too one of our things that we
got well they don't okay so they only
have it in the fall but they did have a
thing that was like a pumpkin chai latte
but you could get it like Frozen and man
that [__] was [__] delicious we were
like so sad when winter came and they
they didn't have it anymore cuz man that
was so good but I will say the best
thing that they have which I think is
all your round it's a
salted pecan
caramel latte but if you get you can get
it hot or iced I've had it iced and
that's good too but if you get it frozen
it is off the chain it is really really
good so that's usually what we get they
have seasonal [__] too but we got one
the other day that was like
a I got a peppermint mocha and I didn't
like it as much as I thought I would but
man that salted caramel pecan thing is
like [__] amazing it's like salty and
kind of salty and nutty and it's got
It's I don't know it's got like a really
good like nice rich flavor to it Zan
says Starbucks sucks you can't bring
your gun into Starbucks yeah you can you
can't in Florida Florida's got [__]
you probably could hear Flor you can't
in Florida Florida's got constitutional
carry you can carry your gun anywhere
you you technically cannot take it into
a place place that has that is serving
alcohol but if it's a biker bar you
can cuz uh no every time every time I go
to the Oasis dudes are [__] packing
but I trust all those guys I know them
so uh
yeah Oasis is the
[__] Moss icely
Cantina out of Star Wars that's exactly
what it is
I don't I don't carry myself when I go
there I really I don't [__] pack
anymore I used to but I got all the guns
I need right
here I just I don't want the
Heat and
uh because of the [__] that I do
sometimes my [__] temper can get to
me so I don't want to carry you
know now if I were to like you know a
bunch of money or I was going to go out
to a place where you know there where it
wasn't going to be very
inhabited uh you know maybe I would in
certain situations I will carry but uh
for general purpose there's no reason to
carry here even though it's it's wide
open I never had a reason to carry here
I would feel better if people were just
not um especially places where people be
drinking yeah if you're around alcohol
drinking you shouldn't be carrying uh no
abely really my that that is a that is a
recipe for disaster right there it's
kind of why I'm kind of like nervous
around um mannequins as well well for
lots of reasons but that's another
reason they're checking people though
they they are man Manakin did actually
Implement door people yeah who are they
now charge a cover charge which I'm
that's fine yeah and they also do a pat
down of everybody before you come in
there well it wasn't just pat down they
were using a uh metal detector metal
detector so they do that as well it's
sad that they can't carry a gun it's sad
that they had to do that but I'm kind of
glad yeah I mean it's kind of a federal
guideline that you're not supposed to
carry firearms inside of place that
serves alcohol unless you're which is a
good idea unless you're an agent of the
state you know a cop can't go into a bar
carrying a gun well yeah and I've seen
them do that before cuz I I saw them
come in eye bar and [__] like that like
just in general when you're [__] at a
place where it's supposed to be goddamn
entertainment and alcohol's going yeah
and everybody's drunk It's supposed to
be a neutral area you're not supposed to
carry guns in there even in the old west
they didn't really they didn't allow
that yeah they were smart enough to know
back then it's like that [__] doesn't
mix dud might be drunk and might get
pissed off over nothing and then you
know pull on somebody else and then
shoot somebody in the face or shoot like
an innocent person yeah they're drunk to
hit an innocent person yeah right so I'm
just like it's not a great idea no so in
general that rule is followed here as
far as we know H well Oasis I know isn't
following that rule but well I don't
know the dudes there are pretty they're
older guys and they're pretty
laidback but no I know that in Oasis
there's guys carrying
gun I'm just sorry there are well that
doesn't surprise me I i' I've seen the
clientele yeah the centel MH um yeah so
that doesn't surprise I don't give a
[__] none of those dudes are a threat to
me no I you know I know but it's just
kind of like well I mean you know it's
it's not really my type of place to hang
out in a certain way and I'm saying this
is and this is kind of
[__] this might sound a little funny
you know me being ex Soldier [__] and
a [__] pro gun and [__] in a way guns
are a sign of being weak I agree with
that yeah in certain in certain
situations you should have them in other
situations you shouldn't have them yeah
I don't really like these people that
I'm just going to carry it everywhere
like when you don't even need it I'm
going to go to the [__] like wind
Dixie with like shut yeah you don't need
it you don't [__] need that just stop
it you're just like dick waving or
you're going to go into a [__] club
with it yeah it's like why if you go
into a club with a gun you're a [__]
douche yeah big time it means you can't
throw
Fist and see that's another thing that I
always thought I just always thought
that was you're afraid of getting your
ass whipped so you go to the club like
absolutely and then you're going to
throw your weight around yeah it's like
oh I'm armed right and like I said like
people that it people that carry guns to
places that absolutely should not have
like I said just to the grocery store
and stuff like that I'm like what the
[__] are you doing it's just like knock
it off that's just like those dudes that
drive those big ass trucks that probably
have Micro penises it's just that's
that's what it reminds me of yeah to be
honest with you it's just weakness it's
weak I would only do it in a time of
emergency
you there's a natural disaster going on
or like the cops AR or a zombie
apocalypse zombie apocalypse or uh
[__] other other [__] like you're
delivering a [__] ton of cash or money
to the [__] bank yeah all that [__]
yeah there's a few situations where yeah
that would be warranted but most of the
time no why would you need that me
personally I really only see them as in
times of
emergencies
hurricane okay in in the South that
usually means hurricane
during Hurricane there's no Police
Service okay there's looting that's a
possibility yeah well powers out for
weeks at a time right so you're back to
the Stone Age or the old west yeah you
know what I mean so that's a very
different situation though I mean it's
not that bad I was here in when we had
like four hurricanes SL tropical storms
like within a month and a half period
yeah we our power was out I think
for 8 Days nine days something like that
yeah uh we had some damage to the house
but not too bad um also our street
flooded but to be honest it wasn't too
bad um they you know you couldn't drink
the water it was polluted so you had to
boil everything that was kind of a pain
but most people like behaved themselves
to be honest I was surprised and that
was in Daytona that wasn't here now for
you Americans F foreigners listening to
me guns in your house hell yeah yes
because you're a first responder there's
a such a thing as home invasion okay you
got might have to repel a home evasion
bur Tom's getting paranoid because I
always get paranoid because I've been
watching Cold Case Files man I watch
that he doesn't like to watch True Crime
stuff but I do I'm like [__] god
we've been watching Cold Case Files on
Netflix cuz I I don't know why but it's
like I love watching that stuff it's
horrifying but it's also weirdly
comforting I don't know why want to move
my air 15 from the corner of the room up
to the [__] up to the [__]
nightstand last night we watched one I'm
thinking about my R15 I can't remember
where where was that one happened I
think that one happened in New Jersey
actually but it was a woman she was a
teacher and she lived alone in an
apartment and I guess like three
dudes went to the wrong house like they
thought they were going to like the
neighbor's house who had like $155,000
in the freezer or something but they
went to the wrong place and they like
tied her to a chair and like tortured
her and like shot her in the head when
she didn't give him her any information
because she was just kind of like what
the [__] are you even talking about
probably and it was a horrifying so
Tom's like later on like after we watch
that he's like oh my God now I want like
the gun like right by the bed because
after we saw that because you know you
know what I mean but I got a [__]
great ar5 for that [__] it's weird
because I write about True Crime all the
time um and I think about it but it
doesn't I don't know it worries me I
guess but
I understand I understand the Tactical
ramifications we're in the middle of
nowhere response time for the police is
going to be [__] 20 minutes 15 20
minutes I don't even know where the
closest police station is not going to
lie I know where the closest fire
station is [__] goes down
in [__] goes down in seconds and minutes
when it does happen um so there's you
got to take care of yourself this is
this is
not Germany okay this or whatever ever
you know [__] uh this is more of the
wildlands and uh you got to you got to
take care of yourself that's in the
rules here now guns in the car yeah yeah
if especially if you got a really
[__] nice car and you're in a place
where there's a lot of car
jackings then yeah yeah but we're not in
a nice car no okay that's why I don't
worry about it I'm like they're not
going they're not going to car jack us
no because they don't want our [__]
nobody wants this which in a way I kind
of like yeah because I'm just kind of
like I can leave it unlocked it's like
no one's going to steal it even if they
did I'm like I'm just kind of like okay
steal it it's insured carjacking
sometimes involves [__] taking your
car but killing you right nobody wants
my car that
badar I guarantee it like I said that's
kind of that's kind of one of the perks
one of the very few perks of being poor
and having a shitty car yeah is that
nobody wants it no one's going to kill
me over that [__] nobody they are not
even going to see that car they're going
to like [__] they to rust on that [__]
piece of [__] yeah cuz it just looks
like like I said and it's a good car
it's super reliable but yeah it's not
it's not uh real pretty so you know what
are you going to do but we're not going
to have that car forever we're going to
get another car soon I know but well
don't get a super nice one because we
don't want to get I'm I'm I got so many
messages telling me yeah go ahead and
get that Kia of
Soul people that have I do like those
people that said that they have they
said that's the best car they've ever
had I do like those I drove I've heard a
lot of good I rent yeah I've never
driven one but I've heard a lot of I I
rented one and drove it I [__] loved
that thing says man I think I could own
this yeah this is a nice little [__]
buggy kind of like a little
miniature van yeah or a little miniature
Jeep but it drives like a [__] little
car there's just something about it I
liked it and I bet you the new ones with
all the [__] Bluetooth and all the
GPS and all that that should be great
man yeah I mean we do need a newer car I
mean that that one's doesn't have
anything on it like yeah go
rest we've been how long we've been
talking man we've been on this [__]
show for [__] hour hour and a half
okay yeah Zan said remember in Cocaine
Cowboys all the civilians were packing
and somebody kill criminals yeah it got
to a point in Miami where it was so bad
that anytime you were going
anywhere um everybody was basically
armed you kind of had to be because like
I said you didn't want to get caught
like in the crossfire of all of this all
of these drug wars I mean it was a big
deal at the time so like a lot of
civilians yeah like gun sales went way
up and people were just driving around
with guns in their cars because you
never knew like when a shootout was
going to happen like on the [__]
freeway or something or at a mall or
whatever because it happened like all
the time like during the 80s 70s and 80s
really really bad like I said people
piss and moan about crime nowadays but
it's like it was way [__] worse back
then way [__] worse people were just
getting gunned down like all the time
every single [__]
day
um yeah Danny said I sleep with a
hunting knife under one pillow and a
machete on the other pillow I'm not that
paranoid um which may I don't know maybe
I should be um like I said because I
read about True Crime all the time I
write about True Crime all the time and
I know about all of these cases that
happened and on the one hand it's like I
know that that could happen to anybody
at any time because sometimes it's just
[__] random you know what mean um on
the other hand I don't know I have so
much [__] anxiety about other stuff
and I worry about other stuff I'm just
like I don't know if I want to expend
that much energy worrying about
something that is very very very
unlikely to happen I'm not saying that
it's impossible obviously it could
happen because it happens to random
people all the time but I don't know if
I want to expend energy worrying about
it you know what I mean cuz I already
have enough to worry about so I kind of
feel like that's what it is it's my
statistical brand brain it's that Spock
brain again my brain is constantly like
going through statistics How likely is
this to happen you know and then I'm
kind of like I'm just like I'm going to
worry about [__] in proportion to How
likely it is to happen to me I got her
back I I I I have the same instincts
fing yeah I'm [__] ready but I
know I know when the the time is right
for that kind of [__] some some things
you know need think it happened out of
the blue but it's very [__]
statistically unlikely even in the
United States yeah statistically it is
very unlikely I'm not saying that it
couldn't happen to you and it does
happen tragically but How likely is it
to happen to you just like a random
person very very very unlikely um so
it's kind of like a plane crash type of
situation and I am terrified of plane
crashes even though I understand that
statistically it's very unlikely to
happen to me but it's the same kind of
thing so I'm going to worry about it in
proportion to How likely it is America
tends to follow certain
rules it's the rules of the law of the
Jungle the appearance of weakness is
weakness they'll attack that if you
don't appear weak then you're kind of
more invulnerable unless you're in
involved in something like these guys
here in [__] Cocaine
Cowboys where you're you're a criminal
and you're making a [__] ton of money
and you have a bunch of enemies yeah
they going to come for you it's a
different I mean eventually yeah
different game but they seem to in
general you're choose in general they
seem to know that yeah they know that
but in general here in the United States
uh you're judged by how you look if you
look weak then you're weak and then
they'll come for you but that's on but
then that's raw statistics it's just
that you in a [__] parking lot in the
middle of the night you know what I mean
yeah you might get targeted but not me
and Jen not the way we not the way we
are not where we go our habit also avoid
most of
that a lot of it has to do with your
habits and knowing where you are it's
called situational
awareness like you know the places that
you're going you know who's going to be
there you know what the you know what
the crowd in that area is going to be
like because you've been there before so
a lot of that has lot to do I mean I'm
not saying bad [__] hasn't happened like
on the way to those places cuz I
remember specifically when we were
leaving iar when night me having like
burn a [__] on the arm with a
cigarette who was grabbing at me
remember in front of the pizza place
where was this coming back from iar this
was years
ago I was like pretty drunk too so I was
all so I was all full of piss and
vinegar yeah you burned him on a [__]
arm with a cigarette well yeah he
grabbed me I was with you I think you
were a little bit in front of me he
grabbed me and I had a cigarette in my
hand and I was like oh
[__] he was like you [__] I'm
like yeah
well don't [__] do that maybe now you
learn but you know what I mean you
[Laughter]
know yeah yeah burned a hole in his arm
yeah but um hey I had it I forgot all
about it it it was a weapon so that was
just random [__] I mean I probably
should have stuck it in his eye that
would have been better that have been
right near the police department then
but yeah well yeah the police department
was right there so I was like well I
don't want to get in too much trouble so
you know I'm going to shoot somebody
over there and the arm was just right
there so I was just kind of like oh well
arm time remember time we walk over by
one time the flicking old uh the two
black dudes one of them [__] reach up
there and grab your booty and then we
turn around we both put on that
[__] [__] you do grabbing a
motherfucker's ass and he could have
been our kid sure yeah I think a lot of
them think St for his friend yeah and I
think a lot of them think that no one's
going to call them out I called that
[__] right out cu they're going to be
like too scared about it and I'm just
like well especially when I'm drunk I'm
just like oh I will absolutely get all
he's a big dude but I just I [__] what
you grab a motherfucker's ass for I'm
grab your ass who you then the cops
jumped in right remember the the cops
you you the cops are right there just
[__] fun of games like I said where
iar used to be yeah iar was right in the
corner next to it was a pizza place next
to that was the entrance to the parking
garage next to that was the police
station yeah right there like right
there in between all that right there
was a [__] another club there that
for sometimes did [__] hipop nights
yeah that's and that's that's what was
going on there that one night yeah cuz
that was like the back entrance cuz that
was like behind and old boy was probably
like [__] 21 and he was [__]
showing off for his friends of how
[__] cool he was you weren't that
cool dude you're not that cool you're
not that cool oh boy just grabbed some
girl's ass that was like walking by good
for you yeah we both went up on him who
the [__] you grabbing people's asses for
he's like well I don't I don't I don't
know [__] stupid
[__] I don't know I don't even know
what my hands I I didn't know I was
grabbing anybody's ass yeah I grab
dude's ass I
you grab your ass I'm grab your
ass be like what you some kind of punk
said me [__] you ass make me a punk
then I I guess I'm a punk cuz I'm going
[__] you deep with your ass [__] bust
all kinds of nuts up in there you're
going to be digesting all kinds of my
children up your lower
intestin that makes me a punk and I
guess I'm a punk okay you going to be
pregnant when I'm done with you yeah
[__] ass ass pregnant
yeah okay look we got to shut this [__]
down man
I I'm hungry yeah I'll I'll get
something to eat all right we've we've
wandered about steak and shred and quad
no this [__] too [__] long we were
talking about this [__] let me plug it
before the end show we were talking
about this we're still talking about
Florida so it's C Cowboys reloaded
reloaded this is the 2014 version this
is a [__] excellent version my boy Z
send this to us this is a great movie
like I said don't watch it if you're
squeamish though because there's like a
real a lot of [__] up crime Haven seen
photos in this it is a documentary that
beats a action movie you'll enjoy it
more it's really happened it really
happened they show some of the [__] they
show the real smug cocaine that's the
lesson then they got a fantastic [__]
new way uh uh new retrowave [__]
soundtrack to it it's a great it's a
great [__] flick and this will Miami
this will enter my [__]
library of [__] in his man C Cas my
in the man C Cas into the library
of
Eternity okay wow that sounded yeah you
know he Superman he's got the
[__] what do they call what what the
Fortress of Solitude of solitude that's
just the man cave of Eternity I like
that I was going to say that just like
on MST when they were talking about uh
pum man and they were talking about
[__] Donald Pleasants and they called
it his Fortress of
balud Fortress of balud okay all right
so I think that we should probably call
you your man cave The Fortress of
volitude no it's all right okay Fortress
of
manhood manity that's not quite as okay
what did I call what did I call it what
did I call it man look I'm too [__]
Dr oh my god oh [__] all right smell
that it what is
it wait is that's the same thing I'm
drinking right yeah well why do I got to
smell it it's vodka man I know it is I
also have vodka okay clearly okay
goodbye Tammy goodbye we're shutting it
down we shut it down all right for real
we are shutting it down yeah it's uh
it's Monday night right yeah tomorrow
I'm G to do a probably a book review
I've been trying to do like more
Christmas horror you know what I mean
because the week is I was like holy [__]
like next week is Christmas so I need to
do some Christmas horror [__] so I read
a Christmas horror book and I think
Tammy you might be reading this too
because I think I saw it on one of your
pages I think you commented on but I'm
going to um talk about that probably
tomorrow might be around 3ish something
like that I'm not really sure when I get
around to it and I also watched a
Christmas horror movie which I'm going
to do a review of also either on
Thursday or I might wait until like
Sunday to do it I'm not really sure also
like I said Wednesday night we're doing
a show about the so-called uh Corina
incident or sometimes it's called the uh
I think it's called the Kamar deban
incident which is kind of like de pass
it's kind of like some hikers that up in
the Russian Mountains and stuff like
that and like weird [__] ensued we'll
talk and a bunch of people died so we're
going to talk about that it's super
fascinating I didn't really know that
much about it before someone recommended
it so that's what Wednesday night show
look at it tomorrow yeah yeah yeah and
it's going to be like really there's a
bunch of like documentaries about it on
YouTube which I already have like queued
up all right but yeah so that should be
fun so I will probably see you guys
again tomorrow for a book review um and
then we will see you guys again on
Wednesday night so hopefully you guys
can join us for that thanks for joining
us this evening good